the man behind the the myth the legend
if you will in the jacket
Brock Meyer returning to IFC in season
number two premiering on April the 25th
Hank Azaria good to see you sir
good to be here rich I was a lovely
introduction thank you you know what I'm
also in this just to promote for a
second you can also binge watch and
stream season one on Hulu as we speak
go down to Brock mire wormhole exactly
if you like is that right it's a fun
wormhole by the way that would be a
great fantasy team name by the way
rothmeyer wormhole rock myers wormhole I
might go with that yeah what are you are
you doing any fantasy anymore or what I
am down to one team that I share with my
lovely my lovely business partner Sheena
okay she does most of the work and I
yeah you really productions my now my
producing partner I did not you began
it's my-my humble assistant and is now
my producing partner that you could grow
in the Hank Azaria orbit America's
really the place America only the minute
cuz I know you know you're out you're
out of the fantasy league that you kind
of help create that yes used to all
being together yeah didn't invite this
year so I sorta went with like I guess
that what's happening you know you
saying it's not you it's me
yeah the Commissioner decision was made
in some backroom some since I cut him
out for come on Hank you know I said
that nobody would let me out which is
true I'd blown my old camp buddies my
old LA buddies and my New York friends
and I was like you know guys I need to
cut cut back cuz it's too much time and
everybody got pretty upset and then
everybody threw me out and now I just
know you just got one now just with I
know it's it's it's interesting that
you're you're now you know you're you're
now just it's Connie you're like kind of
Corleone II at the end of Godfather to
right you're you're isolated you're just
you're just isolated you're in a cycle
yeah
which Corleone er you talking about
you're like your your isolated in your
fantasy world run just don't ask me
about my business
the Mets man you gotta be sold a minute
you are either ecstatic or you're you're
thinking that this is setting up some
form of september/october trap door when
I am both of course music yes okay Wow
music video popped up but what does he
know it was no no send drummer in
silhouette to Katy Perry stuff that you
watching this current incarnation of
American Idol I'm enjoying it yes yes
but more important the Mets has all Mets
fans I am a combination as a met fan you
learn to enjoy while things are good
which are very rare yes and to
completely expect destruction around the
corner and you're usually right
I saw a stat on ESPN can I say SPN here
please and the mothership does your dad
like to call it yes in the wild card er
like the last 25 years like 10 teams
have started 11 1 as the Mets did and
out of those 10 like 7 missed the
playoffs and 3 were out in the first
round to leave it to a med fan to find
the Nugget of depression hold on hold on
to that but it's best to manage respect
ation the Nugget that I saw on the
flipside but it also does speak to the
difficulty that they've had more often
than not is that this past week was the
first time that they had syndergaard
degrom yeah Harvey Matz and wheeler all
lined up to start yeah and they all made
their appointed starts yes it's the
first time that it ever yes and for
those of you playing at home and who are
fortunate enough not to be Met fans that
was supposed to be like the that's it
the power 5 those are the young arms
that yes and everyone's been hurt or
lost their minds in one way or another
and this all the that was only
accidental zelenka's Jason Vargas who
they picked up got hurt because we were
they sent back down to the minors you
get a terrible end of his spring
meanwhile his start was brilliant art of
all so go figure this stuff not as good
as Bartolo
last night the ex met I will get that
later Jim Brock Myers getting out to
talk about that okay he's very excited
yes but they're actually the starting
pitching has been good not great yes but
I think what what I as a met even as a
doom saying met fan yes Mickey Calloway
and Dave Eiland feel real the way they
can nurture the pitchers and and
actually manage the bullpen feels like
you can actually count on that however
else the season goes mm-hmm so you're
feeling good in other words as good as a
met fan can feel unless you unless it's
1986 you know and the ball has just
rolled between Bill Buckner's legs have
you because I know you are social media
savvy and active have you seen
Hernandez's joined Twitter
have you seen Keith Hernandez know Keith
is on Twitter Keith is now he's tweeting
like pic ashtag mustaches and always
tweeting out pictures of his cat yes
paragraphs on Twitter yeah about what is
cat it's just having dinner with us
covered Twitter like oh I can say
whatever I want or it is on the screen
right there
don't worry [ __ ] daddy will be home
tonight
is him or is this his team just proud of
his kitty you know Jim Brock Mayer is
gonna interview I'm not kidding Keith
Hernandez in May next month I think he's
got a new book that's coming up that's
what it is he's got a new book coming
out so he's getting ahead of that with
his social media you can promote the
book Brock Meyer Keith Hernandez is a
heck of a summit here's one 33 minutes
ago I'll be sporting my thomas jefferson
overcoat tonight
I bought that coat after the 86 World
Series I noticed it on display four
weeks prior at a small men's clothing
store near the Plaza Hotel when we won I
figured I was getting his nice winning
chair so I treated myself and pounced
there we go
I guess that was terrible seriously III
fell asleep woke up fell back sleeping
sleep saying the in the in the course of
that so this that mean you don't have a
Thomas Jefferson overcoat well we all
have Thomas
oh speaking of Mickey Calloway I had
scheduled today at noon this is three
hours ago I had scheduled today at noon
and City field commercial shoot for New
York lotto with our new manager Mickey
Calloway but alas even this ugly spring
has descended upon this task postponed
due to inclement weather strike a
familiar sound see you tonight
it's pouring all morning here you see
this is they shouldn't have increased it
140 characters they shouldn't have
increased that you didn't think that one
of the greats
in Mets history would ever use Twitter's
traffic and weather together updates on
look quite got the hang yet I've
consecutive tweets about the rain today
a new heart my god he's bored it's him
Thank You Rich Eisen show Jim Brock
Meyer mom I'm out here this is like if
my mom were tweeting this is what would
come out but anyway if your mom also
raked as a left-handed hitter did color
commentating for the Mets yes whatever
the equivalent is I guess pan games are
mahjong games my mother this is the kind
of thing she would supplement that
career with who do you want as the Jets
quarterback
well brothers Hank third overall what do
you want I would go I not just cuz I
heard your your rant earlier I would go
take its take I was a rant really no I
don't know
yesterday was a hot take people like to
say in your business
uh yeah Rock Josh Rosen I like him I
mean I'm I'm a Jewish guy from Queens
yes you know you're a Jewish guy from
Staten Island so we like Josh Rosen
let's let's just be open about it but
it's an interesting year I can't
remember where you have for arguably
five really viable guys who we know none
of us know what the ceiling or the
bottom is gonna actually be but they
seemed like they all could really have
genuine careers as quarterbacks that's a
lot in one yes yes and they all have
genuine pros and cons I think Josh Rose
would be a good fit in New York he could
handle the media and I like those things
about him that some people criticize him
over I I worry about his concussions and
the one thing I'll say that I do
understand is that if you have other
options as a human being right okay if
you can do other things literally when
your head is getting pounded like that
over and over again do you at some point
go you know it's not because I don't
love the sport or not because I'm not
dedicated and committed but maybe from
my health and from my sanity I should go
do those other things I can understand
people worrying about that so you're
saying in other words that it would just
be very jet-like for them to use a third
overall selection on a quarterback who
becomes the first one to ever retire in
the middle of his 20s because he's
concerned about whether he'll be able to
walk in his 30s and think in his forties
yeah like a pull of Barry sander what
Barry Sanders must have done right where
he went it's enough I'm just I don't I'm
not enjoying it anymore and I want to
preserve my health I just didn't get
that from him well yeah I mean obviously
you don't know what he's gonna think
about in his mid-20s because if he he
knows that now and he knows the risks
now and he's he's gotten his head beaten
in figuratively already yeah at UCLA
you'd think that maybe he would tap out
of it now as opposed to maybe in the
middle of it I don't see that I see a
guy who's gonna be able to go to New
York and understand as you point out the
city and the fan base and winning
football games you know it's easy to
figure this out though I actually just
came to me as I was sitting here with
all this debate over who's gonna make it
and what's the right pick yes I think
it's so obvious what is it whoever
Cleveland and the Jets take will not
make it
and whoever anybody else takes well
interesting yeah
so history is on my son should I start
the NFL draft coverage that way and a
couple of Thursday's you know as you and
you boat you and I both know that it's
probably correct so hey everybody
welcome to the NFL Draft here on NFL
Network and Fox we all know when the
Giants are second overall but that's the
future Pro Bowler picks one three and
four smoke him if he got him we'll see
him pick five as Jim Brock Meyer once
said yes you know if the Patriots had
selected Mark Sanchez he'd be Tom Brady
but as soon as he was in green and white
he was destined to slam his head into
his teammate and and and fumble the ball
up with some buddies but on Thanksgiving
where no one
watching yeah that's just that's the
price of having jets on your helmet and
what do you what do you think the Knicks
should do at their head coaching
position Hank I don't know
you know I lucky enough to be a
celebrity Rich Eisen and to sit at Level
II celebrity Row where they treat us
well over at the garden which is still
the greatest place to see a game so are
you trying are you treading lightly
right now no no are you treading I
genuinely love being at Nick games
garden okay and so you know as a fan you
sit there even as an idiot fave and Eve
you don't know anything but you love the
next you go here's what I would do give
some idea in your mind what you would do
I have absolutely no idea so Gandhi Van
Gundy you want him back that would be
fun but I what's this do you think that
would be a I think Mark Jackson is
awesome I think I can even see David
Blatt a case for him or visit al
whatever his name is or Jay Wright if
we'd be lucky enough but but whoever the
coach should be I don't know and what
would you do what would you do what's
the first priority with this team it's a
complete rebuild right can i fire the
owner no okay I may not fire the owner
do you know that he is he he is he owns
it was my boss he owns IFC you know he
is owner of AMC networks in many things
he owns an AMC network is an is an IFC
oh no that absolutely so any sort of
anti Dolan sentiment no no no all at
risk
well not the Simpsons The Simpsons
worries on a totally different it's a
different thing but no I all I'm saying
is I don't know I'm sure there's a fix
for the Knicks I don't know what it is
and I have truly appreciate how well
we're treated at those games and I love
being there and I appreciate mr. Dolan
support do you have JD in the straight
shots greatest hits the you know there's
album that says that's his band oh right
yeah I do not have those greatest hits I
don't have them do you want them yes
I do I why not okay
Congrats on broth Meyer it's already
been picked up for season three and four
as well is it yes three and four and
we're about to get season two yeah
fantastic
yes it drops it drops on a 125th on the
Joe Buck's birthday and my birthday is
that right yes no you and Joe birthdays
also al pacino who we mentioned tonight
already okay and Ella Fitzgerald oh and
Renee Zellweger all of us April 25th Bo
that's the most bizarre Battle of the
Network Stars I'd be a great starting
five that's right all you need is just
Gabe Kapler and Howard Cosell at the mic
aisle Congrats by the way the the the
the the Brock Meyer code is in the Hall
of Fame I heard in the base that's right
and Museum Jim Brock Myers gonna discuss
that with you I think when he comes out
antastic yeah he's but true that's real
he's yeah it's the whole thing so weird
it's an amazing what this has become
yeah I'm so happy you think you're not
as happy as I brought my returns to to
Jim Dillon's IFC coming up on April 25th
eight episodes of season number two I
know we'll turn it around mr. Dolan I
have faith in the in the next it's gonna
happen that's yeah I'm I'm with you
hank azaria here on the show at hank
azaria on twitter so brought you you
have to run in Brock Meyers coming out
next yeah I gotta go but Jim Brock Meyer
I can take over there we go
I like that set up okay Hank Azaria
thank you for being here on the show
thanks for having we come back the great
legend of the booth himself Jim Brock
Meyer who we've known since the days of
the Rich Eisen podcast hide the booze if
you have any other what do we have any
out here fantastic hide the drugs hide
the booze everything okay Jim Jim Brock
Meyer when we come back here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience